hello welcome back to game sports
coverage of e3 2015 i'm joined by nick
and mike from bandai namco entertainment
america what's up guys repping those
dark souls 3 hoodies yeah yeah to you
must be the envy of everyone else on the
show for got to got a little hike on
there as well and Dark Souls 3 the first
two games it almost it's strange to talk
about Dark Souls 3 in the sort of the
gaming landscape we have now because for
a long time it was just out there on its
own doing its own thing and then people
have kind of gotten used to water darks
like what a Souls game is you guys made
a genre out of nothing and what is it
that Dark Souls 3 is sort of doing for
fans of the series to something bring
something new and to what is something
we kind of we know a lot about now well
I think there's a lot of feature of
elements as well as brand new features
being brought for the the series but you
know Miyazaki son who's the director on
Dark Souls 3 has said that instead of
mashing up you know demon souls Dark
Souls 1 and 2 into one giant dark souls
3 game he wanted to take the best of
each one and really craft something
that's the best of all the series so I
mean do you think that's definitely a UH
on point up you're all right thudding
just lean back yeah here we go some of
new stuff for players to see his kind of
is the first game made for next gen or
vs gin so you're gonna see a lot of you
know increased the graphs are a lot
bearing was the day out there before a
lot more ambient effects windblown ash
cloth physics dynamic lighting so no big
thing with dark souls 2 we kind of
brought in with the torch and the light
and shadow and this one we're able to
really take that to affect in a in a
ways that think you know fans one with
to where we're gonna bring it with every
so yeah the torches in there we're also
giving a player's a lot more combat
abilities as well kind of i speaking to
the sort of technical aspect of it as it
is coming at ps4 xbox one and pc as well
correct so i guess you guys were kind of
hamstrung for a while there with the
older consoles like trying to to make
games that can look good on new consoles
but also like perform well and are you
guys going to put some extra effort into
the
the pc version this year as well or do
you feel like you're sort of on par with
the console so no so it's a direct exit
11 only and they're really taking
advantage that you know from software is
really take advantage of the graphical
capabilities of the new console so it
gives us very immersive experience for
the player so you know the
interconnected world that was in one is
now back and 443 anything you see in the
distance so if you see a castle way off
you can travel to real-time rendering so
in this kind of dark dark you know
apocalypse typesetting there's still
also a beauty element to it so there's
that golden sky that you see so there's
dark and gritty but there's also this
beauty to it so mean it sucks i was
really careful to kind of put that in
there so i'm from software i've had a
busy year at blood-borne did incredibly
well on playstation 4 and miyazaki Tom
must be very busy as well is he still
working on blood born with the expansion
stuff or is he focusing on Dark Souls 3
now Oh to me they seem like magic
workers I don't know how they go from
scholar person's blood born to Dark
Souls 3 you know the game is coming out
pretty soon too so it's amazing that
they actually can do all these things at
the same time but I mean what is that
what you think probably yeah and
Miyazaki has been with Dark Souls 3
since the prototyping phase and he's
hanging all the level design and stuff
so he's hands-on with this game
blood-borne stone his game so I really
can't say what he's doing right now so
yeah but is in it deep with Dark Souls 3
but definitely a lot of learnings from
from all the series as well as
blood-borne really kind of a lot of
learnings that are applying for the
dorsal story series and from what we've
seen from from dark souls 3 we haven't
seen a lot yet I've folks are like dying
for gameplay I'm sure at this stage and
it seems like it might be some narrative
tie backs to the first game can you guys
speak to that at all or is Miyazaki some
kind of holding on to that himself
because the Dark Souls games have always
been kind of similar to final fancying
that they were kind of their own little
things in my take it is the same thing
again so you definitely don't to play
one and two in order to enjoy three
there isn't really this kind of there's
a world connection between months 1 2
and 3 and the world is coming into this
kind of
apocalyptic ruined state but there isn't
one overarching there that kind of ties
all three together I'd say but there's
definitely a more increased storytelling
element for dark souls 3 okay great yeah
definitely it definite takes place in
the same dark souls universe but when
and where that is this were not talking
about that quite yet yeah well no born
when you release the Dark Souls MMO and
it's all good i guess it won't living
breathing world we're living our living
dying world yeah I'd say uh probably run
that game's called Tommy is when we're
probably release our next big big
trailer for a lot of gameplay so yeah
something you're gonna start showing
some gameplay you'll start seeing that
come out of that tight timing areas
awesome it's interesting more and more
games comments becoming a bigger player
and someone from Europe I really like
that because we used always go to games
common now it seems like a lot of
publishers are setting stuff up for e3
and then smacking it win again that way
we don't wanna do that it's a lot of
hard work obviously now III and games ID
like six weeks apart maybe to condense
that so it's like but you know the fans
want it and it's a huge event and so
that's our big next follow-up after 33
also mad before I let you guys go kind
of want to talk a little bit about the
combat and again not to keep going on
about Sony's little project but
blood-borne and did some really
interesting things with this sort of
reports them with the counters with a
gun and whatnot I think people are going
to be very excited to go back to sort of
the pure dark souls sword and shield but
has there been anything else sort of
have you guys changed any of the the
format in terms of combat at dark souls
3 yeah which from software has added
some new abilities to the combat you
still have the light and heavy attacks
like you have from previous Dark Souls
games but now if you to hand your right
hand weapon you can go into different
stances so with short swords you're able
to go in this ready stance and kind of
do alternate acts week and she'll break
someone do this lunging the attack great
swords are able to kind of lean into
attacks absorb some hits you know and
kind of do more devastating attacks so
it's a risk reward system if you don't
want to use those you don't have to you
can always play it the regular way if
you want to but they're making a lot
more a lot more options to the player
play how they want to play but yeah in
the first luck demo with music son of
any time he dealt
new sword fighting action abilities that
the the response is always a definitely
looks really cool awesome I think it
like Bonnie and I'm for entertainment
america thank you so much for coming on
and we're gonna see some new gameplay
games com and when is dark souls 3 gonna
be out early 2016 for xbox one
playstation 4 and pc awesome thanks very
much your time gentlemen i really
appreciate it and we are still live here
on the game spot III show for much more
interesting stuff coming up we got the
guys food gorilla coming on to talk
about rigs which is a game we saw just a
little bit of at the Sony conference oh
I'm going to try to get some more
information about that but first of all
we're going to check in with the game
spark room at Mass Effect this segment
of course brought to you by our friends
at msi check it out